mutual inverses what do I mean by this
when you have a function and you compare
it to its inverse right one of the
examples we had a look at before was
things like say that I think might have
been the first effects we looked at and
we found that its inverse was was it a
third X plus one I think it was right
yeah so what you're doing here like what
are the instructions here take a number
and import multiply it by three and then
take away one and this does everything
but opposite it's like we'll add one and
then divide by three right so inverse
functions they're kind of like bivvy
the controls in of function world okay
it's just like whatever you did I'm
gonna undo it okay
and so because this undoes whatever it
is that this does something unusual
happens when you put one function into
the other we call this composing when
you compose one function with another
and we'll take this as an example
okay so underneath where you've got this
just right down with me right as an
example if you take f of X but instead
of putting in X or a number like three
or eight or something like that
if what you put into f of X is its
inverse right so that's why I've got
these big square brackets I can
distinguish between them okay something
weird happens watching this I'm gonna
write f of X which is this but
everywhere I see X I'm gonna replace it
with the inverse function okay which is
which is this guy right so watch what
happens here is the inverse function
right there so you can see the inverse
function f of inverse F inverse of X has
been replaced into X here right three
times that take away one okay now watch
what happens is you start to like just
unpack this algebraically right what
happens is that 3 and that 1/3 yeah just
cancel each other out so you just end up
with X plus 1 and then there's just take
away one hanging out on the end right
what does that become a X oh and this
was that what happens if you put the
inverse inside the original function
what happens if you did it in the other
direction if you took the inverse
chin and what you put in was not X or a
number what if you put in the entire
original function f of X okay well let's
give it a go here is the outside the
inverse function right a third of
something plus one but there's something
that I'm going to put in is the original
function regional function which is
there right 3x minus 1 like so right so
you can see there is the original
function sitting inside and just like
before if I just start to simplify on
auto-pilot what I normally do what
happens inside the brackets you just get
the minus 1 the plus 1 just cancel each
other out so you get 3x in here and then
you're like wait a second that's just X
again now think about what this is right
you start with something right you do
something and then you undo it
unsurprisingly you end exactly where you
started
does that make sense you do you undo or
you under you then you do you're always
going to come back where you began which
is why we call them mutual inverses they
kind of both undo each other which is
what mutual means okay so for this next
bit if you've got everything underneath
this mutual inverses Business written
down all these space for this subheading
because I don't spoil it just yet but
you might have noticed when we did have
very first examples of how to go from in
a function to its inverse I gave you
this linear function and then always
straight to a cubic did you notice that
and you're like gimmicks are hard why do
that why not go to something simpler
like say a quadratic well it turns out
in this particular context I'm going to
show you why the quadratic is not
simpler let's think about this right
here's y equals x squared let's call
this our original function right what
would I do to this to get the inverse of
this now I'm just going to swap this
right so I'm just going to write it an
inverse you can write this with me right
this is original you'll write down well
I'll just swap these guys around I get
this right now this is a function right
in fact I'll just do and you might like
to do this as well just gonna do a
little quick sketch here this is what
that's black isn't it
this is what y equals x squared looks
like ok but this guy here
hmm let's uh let's make why the subject
shall we can we make why the subject cuz
that's what we normally do it makes it
easier to read so I'll just write the
one on the left-hand side watch I did
both sides
I should take square root right so that
gives me just the Y on the left-hand
side I'll get the square root of x but
you guys remember when you've got this
kind of equation you don't just get one
value at the end do you get two you get
plus or minus very good now this guy
here this is a bit problematic because
if you do a little sketch with me now if
you remember what happens when you take
a graph and you get its inverse right
you're doing Adrian but we this is
algebra what's it gonna do visually
right it reflects across I'm running out
of colors right it reflects across this
y equals x line remember that right so
what's gonna happen is you get this
shape I'm deliberately not putting the
same one because they get a bit busy
right so can you see if you sort of flip
it around that way you'll get this shape
now this is not a function what is it
it's a relation because if I get my good
old vertical line out you like what
totally fail right so like this is not
an inverse function so what am I saying
here when you take a function and you
look at its inverse you may not get a
function you may get a relation if I
should write that down right this is a
um this is a relation okay so in other
words and this is probably worth writing
down actually word-for-word
not all functions have an inverse
function
as you can see here and this is the
reason why I didn't include it in our
original introductory examples when you
try and take the inverse of this you
don't get an investment you get an
inverse relation and can you imagine if
you went to your calculator right and
every time you went like take a squared
or something and it gave you two numbers
you'd be like well which one is it
alright you want one answer your
calculator is built for functions get a
number in give you a number out okay so
this is kind of a problem for us right
but we can solve this problem and we're
going to use a technique that we learn
all the way back when we started out
with functions which was if you don't
take all of the original function just
look up for a second look up for a
second if instead of taking this whole
thing you only take a section of it it's
going to be okay right
if for example I just take that part
there right so if I say if I sort of
define it piecewise if I restricted the
domain and said I just want X is greater
than zero right what happens when you do
the reflection you're that visual beam
right which part are you going to get
have a look
you're gonna get the top half can you
see it this one I am willing to pull it
but she does it I am gonna put on the
same one because look can you see there
can you see their symmetry you'd like to
turn your head you're like oh there it
is right so in other words we can turn a
function into an inverse function if
we're willing to only take part of it
right so we say you can um you can put a
name on the subheading now right
restricting the domain if you restrict
the domain of a function if you do it
intelligently you can make sure you get
an inverse function at the other side
and knowing how to restrict the domain
is one of the things you need to learn
about right